hello everybody my name is Daniela
weiskop I'm a research assistant
professor at the La Jolla Institute of
criminology and I'm very excited today
to have the opportunity to present on
our most recent study where we were
investigating like the immune response
to a low-dose mRNA vaccine and if it has
any effect if you have pre-existing
cross-reactive T cells so for the last
18 months I have been spending
um every day to study like how our
immune system recognizes covid-19 and we
have found out that after natural
infection you have a pretty stable
memory response up to eight months for
symptoms outside and this is just the
summary of this publication so when you
compare the immune response parameters
and we have always measured 34 cd8 T
cells neutralizing antibodies and igc
titles so um one month after infection
the majority of people has all five of
these parameters like detectable six
months the majority of people still have
at least three or more assets indicated
here by these blue um little man so we
were interested in okay this is good
news for natural infection how does this
look like after vaccination and the
other question
and um we were interested in is we early
on identified this phenomenon that we do
see cross-reactivity or responses
against star scope 2 in people where we
are very certain have never seen this
virus so about 50 of the people had
detectable CD4 responses that reacted
against peptides derived from Source
copy II but we knew they never have seen
this virus because these were blood
samples collected in 2015 2016 so way
before
um this virus was circulating also we
were certain that they have never seen
the virus because not only we collected
it way before onset of the pandemic but
of course we also tested
um antibody parameters and made sure
they have never seen the virus so these
are the two questions that we had going
into this study so how long does
infection after vaccination lasts after
we knew that after natural infection at
least eight months it has detectable
responses and then what are the what is
the influence of these unexposed
cross-reactive T cells that we have
detected in about half of the people
that have never seen the virus
so
this was the perfect uh core to analyze
this these two questions how long the
seasonal memory lasts in mrna7 1273
vaccinees and that's this pre-existing
diesel immunity influence the outcome of
vaccination and we had access to samples
from the phase one trial of the modern
vaccine but important to point out that
this was like a low dose so this was 25
microgram of the MRNA vaccine which we
by now
um are everything that's given everybody
receives the 100 microgram dose so we we
thought this was a perfect chord because
um first of all how long does piece of
memory last in a lot of this vaccination
and also we thought that like it's
easier to dissect differences in the in
the subsequent immune response if there
is a lower dose if we want to dissect a
pre-existing immunity has influence on
that so this is the vaccine court and
the visa to be analyzed so as I pointed
out we have studied people that have
received in phase one clinical trials
the MRNA 1273 vaccine developed by
moderna and uh NIH
um as I said importantly the load of 25
microgram we studied 35 different donors
and I want to point out that people
spend across all of the different age
groups so we had 15 donors in the 18 to
55 year Perl for age bracket 10 in the
56 to 70 age bracket and then 10 donors
um older than 70 years so we were we
thought it was important because we
didn't want to like um receive or like
you know find out results for just the
young court so we were we were excited
to include donors like spending all ages
so also importantly this is the visits
that we have been studying as you can
see on the right side of the slide so
all of these samples had an enrollment
um yesterday so that means like this is
a blood sample that has been connected
collected before
um they received a vaccine and this is
important because as I pointed out one
major question we had was like this
pre-existing immunity does this have an
influence of subsequent vaccination so
if you don't have a pre-blade then you
don't know which one of your donors has
created this immunity
we then collected um
um two weeks after each of the doses so
they received um on visited five they
received um the first dose of the
vaccine two weeks later we collected the
sample
um uh 28 Days Later they received the
second dose two weeks later when you
received we collected the sample and
then because we were interested in the
durability of the immune response we
waited all the way to seven months after
first dose or six months after second
dose like to collect the blood sample
and see can we still detect all of these
parameters
so this is going back to the two main
questions we had and I'm going to start
with the first question so how long the
season memory last in mRNA 1273 vaccines
and as I pointed out we we are always
interested in studying like not only the
cellular immunity but also antibodies
and so we have also measured that here
so this is the first um slide I'm going
to um show you so if you look at the
antibody responses and this is measured
on the left panel Spike ICT
um specific responses and on the right
side um RVD
um i2g specific responses you know um we
thought this was important measure both
ways because like some vaccines have
only the RBD I didn't see in it and also
like we know it's a major Target of
antibodies but also because this vaccine
in contains the entirety of the spike
protein we wanted to make sure we
measure these balls to parameters so we
saw that significance responses if you
compare it to the pre-blade at all three
post vaccinations were identified the
peak of response was higher at day 43
compared to day 15 so having a second
dose truly has a benefit because it
raises the antibody levels even higher
and we saw also that responses were
maintained up to the 209 days time point
which is like seven months after the
first dose and you can see here if you
look at the lowest line still 100 of
people responded meaning they had
detectable antibodies either way we
measured it after seven months of
vaccination so that was encouraging
because that means like that everybody
still has contextual antibodies even
though they have received a Lotus of the
vaccine
we were then interested
um in doing a more functional readout so
this is why we measured neutralizing
antibodies so that does not mean only
measuring the levels of antibodies but
also how functional are they like can
they actually neutralized so this is uh
um the results from there and you can
see that we did not
um we have a slightly delayed induction
of neutralizing response so on the first
uh two weeks after the first dose we
have about 30 of the donors that have
neutralizing antibodies but after the
second dose um 100 of the people have
detectable unusualizing antibodies
um again the peak response was highest
and say 43 that is the same what we saw
from the levels of antibodies and also
like almost all donors 88 have still
detectable antibodies seven months after
um vaccination
so
next we wanted to go to the T cells
because like um a lot of these antibody
results were already published so we
just wanted to measure like them for in
our own core to make sure that um that
we can our results are comparable to
what has been shown in the literature
but what was not known yet is like
um the exact distribution of T cells
after vaccination and this is basically
how we measured antigen specific T cells
I quickly want to like walk you through
so that you can appreciate the different
ways we were in thinking of this so on
the left side it shows peptide tools
that we have been using so of course we
use the spike pep Deadpool that stamps
the entire Spike protein because this is
the antigen that is covered in this
vaccine but we also covered the knock
Spike protein just to make sure because
we know that a lot of the pre-existing
immune response is targeted against
proteins other than the strike so we
wanted to also like include this
measurement in our essay and then of
course we had controls
um one was like um using um anti-trans
pools from a different virus so we knew
that a lot of majority of people is
exposed to cytomegalovirus so this is a
great control if you want to mesh
antigen specific cells against another
virus so this has been included and then
of course positive negative control cha
and tmsl
to make sure that we can
um
qualify our essays the assets we have
been used is two different ones the
first one is the aim essay and you can
see here in the middle panel
um the markers we have been used to
identify these cells aim stands for
antigen induced molecules and it allows
you to identify anti-transpacific cells
based on the up regulation of activation
markers and why this is important is
because like that is basically allows
you to identify and the trans-pacific
cells irrespective of their cytokine
production so we started using this
essay early on because in the beginning
it wasn't very clear what cytokinesis
virus induces so we wanted to have an
unbiased essay that allows the detection
of all of the 100 specific cells also
importantly this essay will detect for
example cells that do not traditionally
make a lot of cytokinesis such as tfh
cells people are going to help us cells
so this assay allows you to get the
entire day of the Anderson specific
cells
um regardless of what profile the
cytokine profile didn't use however
um just like we wanted to have like
um a level of antibodies we also wanted
to read the functional antibodies as
I've just shown you the same here we
wanted to see the level of untramp
specific T cells but also their
functions so we did
um actually also run in parallel a
traditional ICS essay which is the
interest of the cytokine staining that
means we can identify which one of the
understand specific cells make which
ones of the cytokines or combination
thereof these are the cytokines that
have been um this had a compound that
has been utilized in our essay and you
can see here it's a pretty broad range
it's that spans from th1 cytokines such
as into friend gamma TMF Alpha also th2
cytokinesis interlacking four and then
also other sides or crimes assorted
residency regulatory cells the other
substance of helper cells such as
interlikin 17 or into like in 10. we
have a cytotoxic molecule which is grand
time B just to see if there is another
capability of the cell else to have
phagolithic responses so why is it
important to cast a broad net of
cytokinesis because also in the
beginning it wasn't very clear what
cytokine profile these virus specific
cells will show there was like concern
that they might be biased to th2 which
which was worried which people were
worried about but like more interfere
with like empathology so this is why we
have a broad range and this is why we're
using these two different assets for our
characterization so if we go right into
the results this is um the cd4tc
responses in this case measured by aim
and you can see again a response that
can significantly higher at all three
time points after vaccination
um the first dose already induces a CD4
tissue responses and the trans-pacific
response to 97 it reaches 100 after the
second dose and also is able to maintain
a detectable tb4 teaser responses in 97
to almost everybody after seven months
so just what we have seen for like
natural infection also here we see like
a very durable cb4c service once and
it's important to point out that we are
very confident when we measure like
responses memory responses six to seven
months after infection vaccination this
is probably a good indicator like of
like how the response is going to be
maintained so we do not expect that this
response basically falls off the cliff
um seven months so because you can
already see it's a pretty like spread
row like um containers of the response
so that's encouraging and I also showed
you that we have included controls and I
just quickly want to touch base on this
so one control we have been using
um was the CMV specific response as you
can see here we do detect CMV specific
responses in the majority of the owners
and they are not changed regardless if
you get one those two dose of the
responses and that's important because
that means the vaccine does not induce
um does not influence other undershell
specific cells
um outside of the proteins that are
encoded in this vaccine and according to
this line of course also there's no
change in the proteins
um outside of just like other proteins
from Source copy II so they're also not
changed so just to show you as a control
then the vaccine induced response is
Spike specific
I told you it's important um for us to
measure also circulating T follicle
helper cells the reason why we think
this is important is because this is the
subset that does provide um Health to B
cells to make like
um higher highly functioning antibodies
so it's important to know if this
substance is actually induced by this
vaccine and this is just for the people
that are interested in the way we
characterize these so we know which ones
are antigen specific Stars Kobe 2 Spike
specific
um people are going to have a cells and
also if you look at the induction of
them we see that more than two-thirds of
donors show T follicular Health assault
in the periphery after the first dose
and uh about similar amount of donors
after the second dose and about
two-thirds still have to flexible immune
response of T follicle half a cells in
the for every seven months after the
first vaccination so also here a
different substance of CD4 T cells and
relatively detectable seven months now
ounce
I told you that we are also interested
not only on the level of antigen
specificity for details but also on the
function so this is shown here so um
this is a cytokine essay as I've found
out in the beginning you measure like
cytokines that are produced by each of
these Unity specific cells and we could
readily detect interfriend gamma tnf
Alpha il2 and also the cytotoxic
molecule grandson B and we can see that
readily um peaking after the second dose
but also like detectable um out up to
seven months of the response if you are
studying vaccines you are always
interested on like the
multifunctionality which is basically
um how many different cyber kinds of
cell can produce can it produce like
only different Gamma or more than one so
we were interested in like is there a
cells that can produce more than one of
these cytokines because we know
traditionally from other vaccines that
these are typically in view correlated
with like higher um efficacy of the
vaccine and higher um response
capability of these cells and sure
enough if you look at the the cells that
can produce more than one cytokine which
is shown here for each of the individual
donors and then also shown here as a pie
chart so the broader um the pie chart
divides for like the green the yellow or
the orange pie that means more and more
multifunctional cells are in use and you
can shortly see here in the beginning in
the pre-bleed the majority of cells have
one function uh this increases after the
first dose with more cells acquiring a
second function even more so at this
after the second dose
um where like there is a quite a
substantial fraction of cells detectable
that can make three or more of these
cytokines and that is maintained fairly
stable seven months out of the infection
as a control we run the same analysis on
cytomegalovirus specific T cells and you
can see here that they are not
influenced for the vaccine at all so
there is a certain amount of
multifunctional cells and they remain
exactly the same on every time point
measure
so this is everything I've shown you
about the addition specific CD4 T cells
that are induced by the vaccine one
about cd80s responses
so we measured Spike specific to the 80s
responses and we were we've seen them
significantly induced at each of the
time points again having the peak of the
response after the second dose just what
we've seen for all of the other
parameters we have measured so far and
we do see of quite substantial amount of
responses maintained all the way into
the seven months out so 34 donors if you
want to put that in numbers developed
spikes 640s and after the third after
the first dose more than half of them
were positive perspects this is the 80s
and after the second dose and about one
third maintain um aim specific responses
after the seven month time point and
just like what we did for CD4 we were
not only interested in like the
detection of like that stuff frequency
of these under the same cells but also
the function so if you now look at if
there's cytokines used for any of these
cells you can see um that the cytokines
that are induced are for cdap cells are
in different government in the fossil as
maturity there are some donors that can
induce after the um second dose also in
the liking too
and if you think back I showed you
there's a broad panel of side effects
that we've measured but I've only only
shown you about a subset that forcing
before and cd8 teasers and that is
because none of the other side account
has actually been detected so we've
never seen il-4 induced we've never seen
il-17 induced uh in any of these donors
neither person before for cd8 so this is
why you always only see like a subset of
these cytokines here so again we asked
the question like Okay can this virus
like specific vaccine induced cells
induce more than one cytokine and this
is the same analysis and I've just shown
you for CD4 and also here we see the
acquisition of functions after the First
Source after the second dose and fairly
maintained all the way to day 2029 after
vaccination so again also for cb8 T
cells we saw that the majority of cell
stuff Indio cytokines and what I want to
point out here is like you see that the
number of cytochemist themselves is
higher than detected by the amsc so 50
of the cells of the anti-trained
specific CDA T cells already induced
cytokines are for the first dose this
raises this Rises to 70 after the second
dose and maintains like more than half
of the donors um are able to use other
kind of responses
um seven months out after infection so
that was very encouraging because that
means we cannot only detect under some
specific cells but they are also
functional and do acquire
multifunctional responses
um after first and second dose of
vaccination so in summary
um what I've just been shown you this is
all of the results so we've seen
um a response or induction of antivirus
and CD4 pieces and 100 of the people of
the second dose and this is maintained
in almost everybody or depending on the
parameter you're measuring um seven
months out so you can see we we walked
through like 100 of the donors plus
effects of antibodies 88 of them are
highly functioning 97 are responding
with cd4tif I respond seven months out
and overall by either of the two as
they've mentioned we still see the
taxable to the Apes and responses seven
months out after infections after
vaccinations qualities
so
um I pointed out in the beginning that
what we have been analyzing is not the
vaccine dose that is typically given
right now but the corner of the dose 25
micrograms so we of course were
interested in how does this compare to
Natural infection so we met we picked
samples that we knew have had an episode
of covid-19 and we collected samples
longitude samples for them like you know
six to seven months out of infection so
this is what we have been using to
compare with response induced by the low
dose of the vaccine seven months after
vaccination and you can see here
um for any of the antibody parameters we
did not see any response between the
loaders of the vaccine or natural
infection
the same is true if you look at td40's
responses or cd8 is a responses which
are in the right part of the slide it
doesn't matter if you look at the aim
specific cells or if you look at
cytokine producing cells need to see
before no cd8 there is no difference
between these Spike specific responses
induced by like the anti-transpacific
response or by the by the low dose of
the vaccine so that was encouraging
because that means even a low dose is
able to give you like responses it's
comparable to like people that have
natural infection but of course the
question that everybody was asking was
how does this compare to the 100
microgram dose because like this is what
we have been giving everybody so this is
what we looked next and again I start
with the antibody responses here so the
25 microgram dose what we have been
studying is shown in the gray uh balls
and the 100 microgram dose is shown in
the green balls here and you can see all
of antibody parameters that have been
measured are higher in the 100 microgram
dose so this is not um we are not the
first one to show that that has of
course also been shown by like moderna
and these are the two citations that I
wanted to point out here so antibodies
response 500 microgram dollars are
higher than 25 and that is automatically
probably also why 100 microgram dose has
been used to like going forward for this
vaccination
what about T cells so if you look again
at City 40 cells on the left side of the
panel and to the 80s is on the right
side of the panel you can see that
similar to what we have seen for
antibodies also cd40s responders are
significantly stronger in use with 100
microgram dose as shown on the left by
either the amsa or the ICS essay but
interestingly we didn't see any
difference in the induction of cd8
season responses as is shown here on the
right side so it doesn't matter if you
look at the aim or the ICS you see the
exact same magnitude or
multifunctionality induced by the high
or the low dose
so to summarize this part
um we have been shown that 25 micrograms
of this vaccination uses Spike specific
ITT RBD IGG and neutralizing antibodies
as well as cb4c responses are very
comparable to Natural infections we did
also show that 25 microgram of this
vaccination induces lower Spike specific
ICT and neutralizing antibodies as well
as cd40 responses compared to the 100
microgram dose this is the one that's
given right now
um we also shown that this low dose of
vaccine induces comparable magnitudes of
cd80's responses compared to the 100
micrograms and that was like surprising
um because that doesn't make any
difference if you have the lower the
high dose
um but if you look in close detail the
frequency of positive tonus was a little
bit higher in the higher close group
so
um this was a very um encouraging
because we were able to see after the
low dose a long lasting induction of
immune response seven months out and so
that we could answer the first question
we had how long does fever memory last
in these vaccines and we showed you with
all the different parameters measured
that also in this donors majority of
donors we can readily detect responses
um seven months out after vaccination
even these donors have only received a
low dose of them Taxi so now we were
interested in answering the second big
question we had and this is that's
pre-existing disability influence the
outcome of vaccination
and this was the perfect chord we were
having because as I said it's important
to have a pre-bleath that means like he
has been uh you have a sample available
before these people have gotten the
vaccine and that's important because
like only if a sample if you have a
sample that does not um that has been
collected before vaccination you were
able to determine if the donors have or
do not have pre-existing um teaser
memory and we did this analysis on our
court on the day one sample which is
basically right before they got the
first dose and we saw that our donors
almost fall half and half so half of the
donors do have Spike specifics before
teacher memory half of his own instead
have not so that gave us the perfect
opportunity to now um divide our groups
and say see if there's any difference in
people that have pre-existing season
response which is shown here in the blue
balls are the ones that do not have that
and the middle a paragraph graph to
shows you that all of these pre-existing
cells do actually come from the memory
peace and memory response just as a
confirmation that what we see is truly
derived from the memory compartment
the first question we asked shown here
in the very right part is does this CD4
teaser response that I can use for the
vaccine has any difference in people
that have the pre-existing immunity or
do not have the produced immunity and
you can see here at all time Point
studies there is a higher response
frequency of antigen spike-specific
cells in people that have pre-exist
immunity so that means not only can we
induce a faster response but also a
stronger response and that was true at
all time points we measured all the way
in seven months after vaccination we see
that there is a stronger response in
people that had like seven months ago
pre-existing immunity
what about the other parameters so I
told you that we are also interested
about the functionality
multifunctionality of the teaser
response and again we divided the donors
Into the Blue Group which is half
pre-exist immunity and the one that did
not and we saw that the ones that do
have previous immunity were able to
induce faster and a more uh higher
frequency of multifunctional cells after
the first
um dose but also after the second dose
of vaccination so this also looks like
donors that have principality are able
to induce faster and stronger and
multifunctional T cells
compared to people that did not have
pre-existinated you
what about this
circulating T follicular helper so I
told I told you that these are important
because you wanted to have this subset
because these are the um CB4 teasers
that help generate more robust
anti-trans antibody responses and again
here we saw that in the early time
points which is like the second after
this after the first dose the second
time point which is after the first dose
of vaccination
um significantly higher induction of
circulating T Health response P follicle
help or responses compared to the people
that did not have
um pre-existing immunity that uh
difference when the way if you look
further out of the vaccination but
clearly after the first dose you have an
advantage if you have pre-existing
immunity
so I told you that why we measured tfh
cells is because like they are helping
antibodies
to develop higher stronger
multifunctional and dependent responses
so we asked next if we divide our groups
in pre-existing yes or no
um do we see a different antibody
responses and the answer is yes also
like in the uh antibody response so if
you look at Spike specific icg Fighters
you do see a strong antibodies response
in people that did have a pre-existing
immunity compared to the ones that have
not similar to the people who can help
ourselves also like this response is
most notable in them um after that first
of those and then is uh is going away
the difference after the second dose or
in long-term memory
so similar things we have been seen if
we not look the entire Spike specific IG
but the RFD specific IGG Titus
um where also we saw like a strong
induction after the first dose that is
then like feeding um out the difference
in the other um time points very
interestingly though I told you that
it's important to not only always
measure the level of antibodies but also
the functionality and
um very interestingly and importantly if
you look at the neutralizing capacity of
these antibodies these are significantly
higher seven months after vaccination if
you do see people that have had
pre-existing memory seven months out so
this is important so if you have
pre-existence before TSO responses you
have a higher neutralizing capacity
seven months after vaccination
so basically we can conclude from this
part and answer this question
um that individuals with pre-existing
Spike specificity before T cells
generate early multifunctional C40
response and more robust follicular
health and easier response and faster
antibody response after single
immunization so they truly have an
advantage compared to people that do not
have pre-existing immunity and with this
I like to finish my talk so I think I
hope I convinced you that we could find
answers after the two questions we had
this is the team at the La Jolla
Institute that has been working um
together like for the last 18 months and
I have been acknowledging people that
have been doing the different parts
throughout the presentation with that I
like to stop and
please feel free to like you know email
any questions if you have any thank you
so much